let's go next to our caller from the 4a0
area code who is calling today from 4-8
zero hello David
yes yeah hi my question is related to
the Thanksgiving don't talk politics I
was wondering what you had to say about
that subject oh we did a whole bunch of
segments about that before Thanksgiving
is there I think it's fine no I mean
yeah no I mean the the subject is don't
talk politics of Thanksgiving don't talk
politics with relatives but what about
if you're just in line with strangers
you know people you're never gonna see
again and you're not trying to convince
them don't bow for Trump but you're just
trying to have a little fun would you
ever do that I wouldn't do that but I'm
totally fine if you do it I have no
problem with other people doing that if
that's what they want I tend not to talk
about politics out in the world I get
enough on my show so that wouldn't be my
instinct the last thing I would ever do
in line somewhere or you know if I see
somebody with a Trump bumper sticker to
go up to them and roll down my window
and yell something that I I don't do
stuff like that but if you if you like
that stuff by you know all power to you
okay I don't know if you want to hear
about a short story just happened to me
today all right I'm in line with a bunch
of strangers and the trumpet is going on
and on about you know how Trump support
with blacks is 18 and it's going to go
up to 24% and you know the Democrats why
don't they already decide already and
Hillary is getting in and I mean he's
just going on and on and I'm trying to
you know sort of involved myself in the
conversation and you know but he's just
and he says he's not really a trump
supporter but you know unemployment's
the lowest in 50 years and it's just
it's just I mean I just don't know what
what we can do because so did you get
involved or not did you jump in no I
tried to I try to and the whole
conversation started with he was he was
trying to sort of defend the Catholic
Church
because they just recently I think in
New Jersey there's a new law that the
statute of limitations there is no
statute of limitations for you know
Catholic abuse so he so the other person
line was an attorney saying you know
like that's a big business for him is
defending people and then the other this
Trump is just trying to defend the
Catholic Church saying oh it's just the
Internet it's just the media no I I
would not even though it sounds like
these these are conversations with a lot
of people I would I would probably try
to avoid talking to you so that that
would be my advice listen thank you for
the call I appreciate it call back in if
you have any of these other exchanges
they sound they sound intense